[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in jim nance the hall of
famer he was on the call with the chiefs
and the buffalo bills how exhausted are
you after normally after a game and how
did you feel after that game
i'm still tired
i'm mentally still inside of arrowhead i
heard your poll
question there's nothing like a game
that's just pulsating
standing throughout building shaking
like arrowhead so far is the coolest
stadium
but arrowhead
when it's a night like that
pretty hard to beat but i am still
um
having a hard time letting go of that
incredible feeling
and a loop in my mind just kind of
replaying the game over and over again
so yeah i'm still tired you can hear it
i had to i had an obligation yesterday
in new york which
um
it was an all-day shoot so i still
didn't quite have my monday recovery day
and today is just that so here we are
aside from well what play stands out the
most what moment stands out the most
from the bills and chiefs that five
years from now i'll bring up to you
i think the fourth and third team
which don't forget before the play
there was a fan who ran out of the field
and kind of maybe
i don't know maybe change a little karma
in the building or whatever and digs
decked them and it was it was one of the
great tackles i've ever seen by the way
um so i think the fourth and thirteen
then the 64-yard throw to hill but
ultimately
to me the game came down to that kickoff
with 13 seconds to go into regulation
that's the one that i think changed
everything and i got into a little back
and forth with tony i posed the question
you put it on the ground here just
trying to reduce it
to a one play scenario to get yourself
into field goal range if you're the
chiefs and they decided to kick it to
the back of the end zone which gave them
two steps
it was a great moment uh you guys had a
great moment at the end of the cowboys
game i mean that's that's what you want
in in the moment when you say to tony
what would you do we want to know what
you would do we we don't want you
hedging and i i just thought that it was
that was great tv it was great great
moment well you know we walked out of
the booth that night and you always
think you're better when the game is
better and that again is going to be
viewed by some as the greatest game of
all time and it goes to that
length and some of the feedback we've
heard about the game but we really felt
after five years and 105 games we walked
out and said that was our best broadcast
we've ever had and we were just so
excited about it tony in those moments
and his enthusiasm and his ability to
break down the strategy i mean i just
love the guy and he's he's just an
awesome guy to share it with
can you always hear him over the crowd
you ever had a problem
trying to hear him
no no not at all because we have what
you have on right now we have the
headsets on so uh it it it pumps it
pretty much right into your eardrum uh
and i have him
of course souped up a little bit and and
can hear him very clearly but yeah it it
is so loud in there though if i took the
headset off yeah and i tried to have a
conversation with him we couldn't hear
one another
where do you stand on overtime in the
postseason
i think we're going to differ on this
but i think when you get to the
postseason it needs to be tweaked
and i know after the game probably the
chief station was upset with us for
broaching the fact that bills and my
words never had a chance meaning they
never had a chance to go and match it to
me
i think they finally got the regular
season
down
correctly and i advocated for a long
time that they needed to get to
something like that but when you've gone
through a whole season you go back to
july and you go back to camps
and all the different plays and
scenarios you you go through to try to
get to a super bowl
and
it comes down to the team that's going
to win the coin flips going to have odds
that are definitely better than the team
that's going to kick the football as
peter king said so well in his football
morning in america
uh
peter said
okay fan base if you really think that
it just you're gonna just throw out the
old tired go make a play on defense then
why don't you guys kick the football
then why don't you guys go ahead and
defer would you be happy with your coach
if they defer so i want to say this and
i kind of we were rushing to get off the
air but i
i think we got our point across we were
there for new england and kansas city
three years ago and i at that time
advocated that it was wrong what
happened to the chiefs in that situation
and interestingly we were all reminded
yesterday that kansas city after that
game went to the march meetings and
tried to change the rule
and it did not have enough momentum to
even go to a vote
so i just think with the whole season
online
give each team
it's a small tweak actually everybody's
like well how are we going to do this we
don't like the college playoff or the
college over time i think it's just
every team's guaranteed a possession
one possession so if that was this year
you kick the football to the bills
they know what they have to do they've
got to go down the field and match it by
the way if they want to go for two
because they don't think their defense
can hold up
then go for two and maybe win the game
on a what's like a college play if you
will from the three or you lose the game
from there or you kick it and say maybe
my defense got enough rest now because
we took 15 plays to get down the field
and maybe they're not gassed and they
can play but i think you get to overtime
postseason one possession guaranteed
each
yeah i'm fine with it but you know we
grew up it was called sudden death
overtime it's like it used to be called
instant replay now it's called replay
now it's not sudden death over time
everybody gets a possession whatever you
do on that and then after that it's
sudden death overtime
you okay with that
i am you know things have changed there
have been rule changes in the game so
the game that we grew up watching
uh it's not the same i mean it's been
it's been tweaked again to try to make
the game more exciting offense getting a
little bit better of an edge and all
this these games are more high scoring
than they were when we grew up as kids
so yeah i'm okay with it again it comes
down to a whole season and i'm not
taking anything away from kansas city
again i pitched for them three years ago
it was awesome what they did
but i just
you think josh allen never really got a
chance to go down the field and do the
same thing because he probably would
have taken them down the field and
scored i mean it was how about the last
two minutes of regulation 25 points then
another touchdown in the ot i mean it
was
it's
i'm still like i said still playing it
on a loop in my head
and i you know the nfl is in the
entertainment business and what would
have been more entertaining than josh
allen getting another opportunity
and you know you still have commercial
inventory i mean come on that this is a
business here that we're running and
i think you've got to factor that in as
well that's why i'm like you have this
audience
now all of a sudden we let josh allen
come out and come back down and maybe
more commercial breaks let's go get a
couple more commercials well listen no
the reality is you have a set number of
commercials you know that's going in and
once you've gone through your
commercials it's not like your sales
people are out selling
you're in the middle of the game oh pick
up the phone let me call
if you want to buy it spot in extended
place so no you get your inventory and
it stays at that thing but you said the
nfl was in the money-making business
i've got the last bastion of profit for
them
to me it's not those commercials that
you can't sell because you've already
you've already maxed out your inventory
somebody i can't believe no one's come
up with this before someone needs to
sponsor the blue tent
it's unclaimed
it's unclaimed territory i can't believe
it's gone this long you know it's
sitting there how many times in a game
do you see
pull up the blue tent there should be
some sort of sponsored element across
there i got it i got it jim
yeah
viagra
the blue pill
i got it i was thinking i knew you were
going blue
you're not talking anything about how it
suddenly just expands no no no no no no
okay no i just want to make sure
hello friends
hello friend
let's go down to the viagra
okay now the thing is it's got to be i
think in the health care industry yeah
blue cross blue shield blue cross blue
shield that's what it is i mean listen
they're a detroit based company it'd be
perfect for them the blue cross blue
shield blue tech
okay but it's just sitting there unclean
i know come on we need more money jim is
calling the uh
what do you have you have uh
tony uh with the uh bengals and the
chiefs right throughout three eastern on
cbs okay yeah the old afc championship
game back at arrowhead yeah
uh was that where's the bill's chiefs
game rank though of all of the games
whether you watched or you called
i think because of the last two minutes
i'm gonna keep it to this sport i
haven't seen a better game i had that
new england kansas city game i mentioned
before on that short list i had
indianapolis
and new england in the 06 championship
game when peyton brought him back from
18 down and won 38-34
i would say those three games were the
best nfl games i've ever seen
here we are at the end of january we're
a couple of months away from augusta
and
i know people have brought up tiger
could he play at augusta
and
what people don't understand is how
hilly augusta is like it's not a flat
it's one of the hillier courses that
you'll probably play on tour i don't
know if tiger could be able to do four
days of that but do you have any
indication if tiger is going to be able
to try to play it augusta
the only thing i hear is from the people
that are closest to him
that have a voice in the game a few
folks that are on the desk for example
the golf channel and they all have
completely killed the idea that he's
going to be ready for augusta i mean i
would love to see it it's gone it's kind
of been quiet here for a while since uh
since the father-son which
was an amazing thing to see not just
because we saw him swinging a golf club
again but because again you saw his son
hitting shots that
were just remarkable with a way about
him that's just like his dad his
mannerisms so uh
look it's getting close
um
you're right though i want to
emphasize your point
to think that he could walk that four
straight days you know it it he might be
able to play it but what's he gonna feel
like on friday and if he makes the cut
you know now you got two more days on
sunday can can he really yeah the
elevation there
is is something if you haven't been
there
you almost can't emphasize about
everybody that sees you the first time
says man i had no idea like walking up
18 is it's a great climb i don't want to
make it sound like these
golfers aren't athletes but when you're
coming off of what he's coming off of
and the walk up and down and hit side
hill shots and things like that it's a
lot to ask how's your golf game by the
way
i i haven't played a long time but i'm
getting ready to talk about it i'm
getting ready not my game i'm ready to
talk about golf this weekend i'm going
to have the unique
double dip
maybe triple dip
because of the elongated season of the
nfl going 18 weeks the nfl now stepped
right into the weekend they used to
belong exclusively with no football
coverage to the farmers insurance open
at torrey pines in beautiful san diego
it happens to mark our season premiere
of golf
is this weekend so the tour jay monahan
along with sean mcmanus came up with a
great plan it's gonna be a saturday
night finish back east in prime time and
cbs instead of being saturday sunday
daytime will be friday and saturday
early evening slash prime time on the
network so i'm gonna call the golf
from arrowhead stadium
on friday night and saturday night
and then the championship game on sunday
a tradition a new tradition unlike any
other
you got young kids brady's going through
this now his kids are a little bit older
how you know
how long do you continue like what what
would be
what kind of pulls you home
you know i love every minute of it and
i just came to an agreement
a little well not quite a year ago
to keep doing this for a long long time
i love it and you're right it's it's
hard walking out the door
and
you know missing kids games and things
like that we made a little tweak you
know how much i love my home in pebble
beach which i'm never selling and you've
been a guest at my home on several
occasions but we bought we bought
another home to be more centrally
located and get me a little bit back to
my
southern roots i'm from charlotte
originally so we moved to nashville
for the majority of the year starting in
august
with the great bulk of my obligations in
the eastern time zone this is the
perfectly
centrally located place that i could
find i'm an hour and 10 minute flight to
kansas city you know and i think 25 of
the nfl teams are a two-hour flight or
less when you're flying out of monterey
every week it's grueling it was
somebody did a little study on my
my schedule last year and i think i'm
going to be close to 300 fewer air miles
a year and i did it because it's time
you're the greatest currency of all time
in that time what you want is it with
your family so i'm leaving later i'm
getting home earlier and it's um it's
definitely been great to help extend the
career so 300 000 miles
no no i'm not talking miles and free
tickets i'm talking hours oh oh three
hours
oh 300 fewer hours in the air ouch
and on top of it when i would fly most
of the time out of sfo san francisco
it's 110 miles from my house out in
california so
i'm not even factoring in the four hours
a week that i had drive time just to
to get to the airport and back uh so it
it was tough uh you know like we we had
tampa three times at home this year
getting to tampa from monterey was never
easy from here it's an hour flight maybe
an hour and five minute flight it's easy
and it's it's been a great benefit for
me and my family time but again i'm
never we're gonna strategically slot
pebble in there when like the west coast
golf swing is coming up i will base out
of there and in the summer and june and
july i'll be back at our home in
california can you see brady retiring
right now
you know it just seems like it's gained
so much steam doesn't it since about a
week ago at this time it just uh it was
it was something that really all season
long it was a little bit of behind the
scenes undercurrent but now
it's just uh
i think by sunday
it had so much talk i'm not sure
it's not tom's fault but i'm not sure it
didn't create a little
flat
environment and attitude for the overall
team of the bucks it was it was swirling
in the wind so much it became so much of
the focus of the story i'm not sure it
contributed to
them getting behind so big early but uh
i would like to see
he says he's not going to do it
and it's not not his style he says but i
would like to know when he's playing for
the last time like i'm not ready for a
march 7th
retirement announcement i i want to look
down on the field
and and watch him play and know that
this is the last season potentially the
last game
uh i'm hoping for one more
tony
i've just been practicing it let's go
jim here we go
tony
how about my boy frank i know caliendo
had to have been sitting back and had
enough of those scenarios
uh in fact i know he posted some because
tracy showed it to me but um tracy
wolfson
but i i love frank caliendo and i've
gotten to know him a little bit better
in this last year
does that sound about right
uh i don't know i i'm not very good at
that seton seton does al michaels have
you heard his l michael's impersonation
it's been a while okay here you go let's
do it again
and there he goes
that's it
and there he goes yeah i like it and and
uh seton does tony tony romo
jim there's only 10 men on the field jim
that sounds about right that sounds
about right uh hey congrats on the move
there hope the family's great and uh
good to talk to you buddy
always good to talk to you hall of famer
you're a great friend thanks man that's
jim nance cbs will have the bengals and
the chiefs kick off at 3 eastern on cbs
on sunday jim doing double duty with
also the pga tour